Mac Miller has died at age 26 from an
apparent overdose I was just a kid
putting music on the Internet
and then my fans kind of went crazy and
it wasn't until my fans were so
undeniable that people really started
you know focusing on who I was so I got
to thank my fans for everything because
you know if it wasn't for people to
support me I wouldn't do anything this
news comes shortly after he was arrested
for DUI and months after his breakup
from Ariana Grande a source tells ET
Ariana is devastated over the news in
late May grande addressed their breakup
on Twitter calling their relationship
toxic and claiming she dealt with issues
relating to Miller's sobriety throughout
their relationship saying quote I am NOT
a babysitter or a mother and no woman
should feel that they need to be I have
cared for him and tried to support his
sobriety and prayed for his balance for
years and always will of course I rather
be the corny white rapper then the drug
Dow mess who can't even get out of his
house overdosing is just not cool
there's no legendary romance you don't
go down in history because you overdosed
Mac has been open about his struggles
with sobriety and depression over the
years like in this 2015 Larry King
interview I had a drug problem you know
for a long time it wasn't just in music
but I definitely was going through a
drug problem and they uh and and I think
it was more of my state of mind I was
pretty depressed as everyone even while
successful yeah
Miller released his new album swimming
on August 3rd and was set to go on tour
starting in October just 14 hours prior
to the news of his death he posted a
clip of his new song so it goes on
Instagram
[Music]
et has reached out to Millers rep for
comment